foreign
Arkansas hi Teresa how are you
just fine
better than I deserve what's up
well I am knocking on the door of 61. I
have no retirement money saved up
whatsoever I've been working the baby
steps I've got my little thousand
dollars
and
um hopefully Social Security will still
be there when I retired 67.
my question is even though I'm in the
baby steps to my company uh matches four
percent and I'm just wondering if I
should go ahead and be putting that four
percent into my 401k even though I'm
still in baby step two so you're 61 and
have no money
none
what do you make
uh I bring home roughly 67 000. what is
your debt
uh little number 69 000 on what
uh student loan is 11. I have a car loan
of 18. I have a personal loan of 12 and
then uh I guess you could say another
personal loan of 26 on a tractor
why do you have a tractor
uh well we're country folks oh we
where's your husband
my husband is 75 he's drawing Social
Security he is basically
um
disabled I guess you could say he has
COPD and emphysema he's had three back
surgeries so he don't need to be on a
tractor
no I'm I use the tractor not anymore
broke people don't have 26 000 tractors
well I have tried everything I can to
try and sell this thing other than just
letting it go back and letting them sell
it for whatever they can sell it for no
you're paying the difference tractors
are selling right now what's what kind
of tractor is this
it's a Kubota that's a girl cell
uh well you haven't tried to sell this
tractor I well when people say that they
go buy a brand new one for the same
price of what my payoff on it is well
your payoff is a personal loan it's not
a try is it yeah does it have an actual
lien on the tractor yes okay with who
who do you owe Kubota
uh yes okay
well I would go to the credit union and
borrow the five thousand dollars worth
of difference and get this tractor sold
and you need to sell your car too
you guys are in emergency mode girl
you don't buy 26 000 tractor when you're
broke
well this was two years ago before I
discovered Dave Fran see this past March
okay all right what is your land yes
what's your land worth
um
probably a
third or fourth
your land is worth three thousand
dollars
yeah we we it it's we bought it per acre
no
for the whole seven acres
your 26 000 tractor for a four thousand
dollar piece of land
well we hunt and I use it to clear deer
leases and our hunting area and food
plots yeah I told you I was country girl
not criticizing country I love country I
was over Bush Hogan last weekend on my
farm so I got that uh and just because
it's therapy but yeah but okay uh admit
it was a stupid purchase yeah yeah it is
yeah it's part of the moment purchase
yeah okay it gives you Joy but not as
much joy as being as being broke is
stealing from you
yeah and you're starting to look up and
go I need something to eat other than
social insecurity when I get to 66 67.
so yeah yeah I if if I'm in your mode I
am so scared I'm going crazy and I'm
selling tractor I'm selling car I'm
gonna get a two thousand dollar car I'm
gonna work like a crazy person are you
leasing the land did you say dearly
hunting lease are you leasing it out to
people it did no no it's land that other
people own that has given us permission
uh to hunt we're not having to
physically pay for a lease oh you don't
have to pay a lease but you're not
receiving any lease money on your seven
acres
no okay all right that's what I was
trying to get to okay all right you have
seven acres and literally the only value
of it is four or five thousand dollars
yes just 500 bucks in acres at Mountain
Land or something
no it's it it's just it's in between a
bunch of uh errors that and nobody
I mean it's paid for I know I know but
it's just hard for me to imagine land
that's that cheap 500 an acre land in
Arkansas
I mean you must be piping sunlight in
there okay we are all right we are all
right I got you girl only God knows
where we're at I love it I kind of think
I'm gonna like I think that I've got a
feeling it's beautiful I really do but
uh but anyway okay so all right um
what's the student loan Teresa why do
you have a 11 000 student loan
I'm paying on it since 1999.
[Applause]
and did not take advantage of paying the
last three years
so you've got to get in high gear mode
because if you'll get this mess cleaned
off
you can you'll have plenty of money to
save and invest but you got so many
payments coming out you ain't got any
room in your budget to invest and that's
why we tell people to clean their debt
before they take advantage yeah so the
short short answer don't I want you to
get free in a year by selling everything
in sight I want your husband afraid he's
going to be sold next
okay and uh and uh you know and every
deer in the area needs to be afraid
you're going to sell him because you're
going to shoot him and put him on
something and sell him I mean oh my gosh
you're unbelievable you've got to
scratch up every dollar you can clean
everything up and and knock this out as
fast as you possibly can because you
don't have any money to invest you know
what I mean room in your budget with
what you described to me so uh and
you've you got you know as you said you
got six years so we've got we got to
make we got to make hay while the sun
shines and you got to get with it and um
and Teresa it's gonna be it's going to
be extremely uncomfortable just know
that going in because it's going to be
really uncomfortable being 82 and oh she
wrote money 100 and a rusty track but
you're you know what I mean but I'm like
after Decades of living a certain way
untangling that
is much more difficult I think than when
you're living some some way for five
years and you're in you know I mean
you're you're taking a life Theresa and
you're turning on its head I mean you're
going to be doing some really yeah newer
ways of thinking that are going to feel
very uncomfortable but keep pressing
through even though it's hard and every
time every time you do something smart I
want you to say I'm doing this because
I'm a country girl I don't want you to
do anything else dumb and say I'm doing
this because I'm a country girl quit
blaming dumb stuff on country girl blame
smart stuff on country girl because
country girls do smart stuff
and and you know this is what that's
what you're about to do you're about to
do some really difficult things and
people in your life are going to think
you've lost your dadgum mind but what
you're doing is you're trying to secure
a reasonable
last three decades two decades of your
life you know and and that that's very
important to fight for it's very
important to fight for and it's possible
Teresa we've talked to people it's
getable five years from down from where
you are
and it's a completely different
situation so you do you it's never too
late we always get that question is it
too late it's not too for me you know
and not too late but you're trading a 26
000 tractor for 150 000 bucks in your
retirement
you're trading at eighteen thousand
dollar car for another hundred thousand
dollars in your retirement you could
have a quarter of a million dollars set
aside with match if you'll get your butt
out of debt now by the time you hit 67
68 years old you can get there if not
maybe maybe 200 maybe not two and a
quarter or maybe not 250 but you can get
to where you don't have this sense of
being broke and then if you want to go
buy a six thousand dollar tractor to
play with out of your two hundred
thousand dollars and your seventy fine
go do that but otherwise don't no no no
and blame all smart things on being a
country girl don't blame dumb things
don't be a country girl